ce que vous préférez chez vous
la qualité de mes silences
ce que vous haïssez chez vous la qualité
de mes silences
au cinéma ce que vous préférez
au cinéma
les gens et rencontres ce que vous
haïssez au cinéma
est con way le plus grand moment de
votre vie
ouais jeu original la naissance de ma
fille et de pierres
le pire la naissance de tempère
je sais pas encore ce qui vous plaît le
plus dans la vie
après l'amour ce qui me plaît le moins
attendre avant
votre plus gros coup de fric
c'est un truc que j'ai pas fait
justement c'est mais c'était pour faire
monter les enchères pour voir jusqu'où
ils pouvaient aller
le plus grosse perte
bah c'est ça s'il n'a pas fait
votre plus belle histoire d'amour
guillaume
laurent mbassi
soufflage
bas ma plus belle histoire d'amour sa r1
ma fille est la plus minable la plus
minable
le jour où j'ai failli tomber à moins de
noirs ouais qu'est celui de plus sexy en
vous je sais pas et de moins sexy
quand je suis bourré ouais
ce que vous préférez dans le sexe moi
j'aime tout tout
ce que vous détestez dans le sexe
les interdits et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de linda hardy tube abonnez
vous il m'était impossible eux